I'm your host keep ingress all so just a
little bit about me I'm a senior data
scientist at civis civics analytics is
is a software and services company based
in Chicago we sell consulting services
as well as a data science platform which
is software useful for like
consolidating all of your data science
workflows in one place from like
databases and like compute instances to
like how do you deploy some of these web
apps that I'll be talking about today
it's kind of an interesting company and
I get a good mix of like deploying apps
and also like talking to consultants and
the companies that make these so that
will inform a lot of what I'm talking
about today personally I work a lot on
text analytics NLP and working on sort
of the API clients to the software that
we sell I think typical for a lot of
data scientists
I do a lot of my machine learning like
tensorflow like count vector as there's
tfis vectorize like all of that I really
love Python for but I'm a lot more
familiar with viz in our it's kind of
just what I would I have been falling
back on and that's sort of one of the
inspirations for the talk my team and I
were thinking like what is out there in
Python to do data vis so we don't have
to use two languages to do one thing
great okay so why are data science web
apps great and I think they're great
because they enable both like technical
and non-technical users to be more
effective in how they use data so for
example like charts and maps when we see
them we have like sort of you know
natural heuristics where you know like
if you see a bar chart you can see the
relative importance of of to like figure
of two like sizes whereas if you have
two numbers it's just harder to do and
and web apps are like a good way to show
charts
there's interactivity in web apps and
this is kind of great because like
before if you just send somebody like
one thing like one chart they might be
like oh that's great but like did what
if I were to like look at that among you
know just this kind of like person or
like this filter and you'd have to send
like that person to question and then
they would like misunderstand the
question and it would take a long time
going back and forth whereas now you can
just build an app you can just like
click a filter and just look at what you
want and they also encourage
reproducible results so if you are
putting data in slide and you like make
changes to the slides you maybe can't
exactly do that again and then someone
will ask you like in two weeks like why
is this happening and you don't know
because you can't reproduce it awesome
so I want to be concrete about what I
mean by a data science web app I don't
think that's really a common term and
I'm using it as sort of to sort of
encompass like like the Jupiter
notebooks are shiny dashboards like the
whole landscape I'm kind of excluding
like custom built like react or or d3
apps it's kind of arbitrary but I think
that sort of that's what I mean is like
these apps that are written in our
Python and that gets translated to
JavaScript I think they're usually kind
of small just like a dashboard or a
couple of tabs if they get bigger maybe
it does make sense to to do something in
a proper JavaScript framework and they
usually include like charts or or Maps
okay so why no JavaScript this is sort
of like another this is like great
evidence but some evidence from the sack
overflow survey that like among
developers like data scientists machine
learning specialists they're like they
want to learn Python there or they want
to use Python there I like the top of
the developers who want to use Python
whereas they're at the bottom of devs
who want to use JavaScript so like you
can kind of say like these people want
to want to work in Python they don't
want to work in JavaScript JavaScript is
also just another thing to learn so I
think I understand like just is faster
to use the language yard
okay so here is an example of of an app
this is a very useful app that lets you
change the color of the scatterplot
the reason I'm showing this is because
this is built by Marshall as he put on
the top by Marshall he's our director of
product so he's he's use our in the past
but he's doesn't code in his job you
know he's in product but he thought like
these apps are so cool this is this is
so fun like kai build one and he did in
like 20 minutes
so I think they're they're pretty easy
to use the fun and I think they're
especially nice as an alternative to
like the default which is PowerPoint
this is my presentation is made in
Google slides it's made in size and it's
great for presentations but there's like
a lot of limitations when you're
delivering like data analysis I don't I
don't think it's like a great medium
because it's hard to programmatically
update you'll send someone the slides
and you say like here's the latest
version use this one and then they use
the other one and we'll be wrong then
there's formatting it's hard to put text
next to plots and I think it can be a
headache and in tableau is a little
better tableau is pretty pretty quick to
build dashboards the consultants I
talked to on my company do you like to
use tableau for some things but it also
has limitations and it doesn't natively
like interact as well with with the code
everyone's writing okay so now I'm gonna
go through like a flowchart of sort of
building these apps kind of based on the
apps I built but also talking to other
people so the first question is always
did this stakeholder ask for a
PowerPoint presentation and the answer
is yes okay so then you say can I change
the mine but it's also not a joke
because I feel like this is sort of what
you have to do this is the position
everyone's in it's like what how can you
convince someone to change their mind
that they don't want PowerPoint so maybe
I will have given some examples about
why PowerPoint is not as good because of
it's not interactive and it's not
programmatic okay but let's say that you
can't so then you might say like how
about a PDF instead PDFs might be a
little easier to create so based on this
answer
you would you know you could use you can
create a PDF with like our markdown or a
notebook and use mb converts or you
could create a PowerPoint and use some
there are some packages out there to do
this they're not terribly easy to use
and they don't always look great it
requires some work okay but let's say we
live in an ideal world and we were able
to convince the stakeholder that they do
want to do science web app so then do a
quick aside so the first kind of thought
or the first kind of session we need to
make when we make a web app is like what
kind do we make do we want to make just
front end only which is just just like
HTML with JavaScript in it or do we want
a server as well there's a lot of
advantages to just doing a front end
only out because you can deploy it on
like s3 on it's just kind of simple -
like - to maintain it doesn't have a
server that could go down and then
someone calls you and you're on vacation
and there's a lot of there's a lot tools
out there that will translate your
Python code directly to JavaScript so
everything can run in the browser for
example HTML which is like our and
crosswalk is all our ipython I PI
widgets also known as Jupiter widgets
there's also I pi which is J's link
which is really cool and that like will
translate reactive kind of like
interactive widgets so you can do
filtering of your charts and that and
that's all in JavaScript so can fit in
the front-end front-end server this
allows you to like Access database and
basically do anything you want and run
custom R and Python code okay so given
those times constraints the first
question we'll ask is like can our data
fit in the browser so if we have let's
say we just have an aggregation of some
data so we have like a few thousand rows
and it's it's easy to fit so yes okay
the next question that we would ask is
do we have specialized code that we want
to execute at runtime so um we can we
can translate some Python code to
JavaScript but if we have like a
scikit-learn model that we want to run
that's not gonna we can't really
translate that to JavaScript
interestingly there are some packages
out there to run and even train
tensorflow models in in the browser
which is kind of
a brave new world okay so no so we don't
have any special code we're just showing
a dashboard then we can use some of
these tools to do that and this is just
like a front end only HTML would be our
deliverable okay so if our data camp in
the browser we need to access a database
then we need to take a different route
or if we have some like optimization
code something special that we can't
translate to JavaScript we also need to
ask this question so next one can you
ask viewers to run your code so if this
is code that you know you're just
sharing with your colleagues sharing
with people at your company or if it's
public then you can just share a
notebook that's really great it shows
all the code how you did it and then all
the charts
there's our notebooks or stupider
notebooks kind of does assume that the
user is technical I don't think that you
would necessarily like pass a notebook
along to like your CEO unless you CEO is
like a computer programmer so if so if
we can't if the data is like not we
can't share the data we can't show the
code or the users not technical then we
need to build sort of like a front-end
server app shiny is like definitively
what you would use an R in Python I
don't I don't really know what the
standard is it could be okay it could be
- so there's not a standard there so to
recap there's like kind of four
deliverables I think there's like
read-only reports PDFs slides you have
to send somebody something new when you
want to like make a change then there's
the web apps which is like front-end
only single HTML page some limitations
of data size and what can be converted
JavaScript shared code this is what I
mean by by notebooks I don't know if
that's the best word but that's kind of
the conception like you just pass over
everything and they can just rerun it
there are ways with like with like
binder to like embed notebooks in the
web so that someone doesn't have to have
the same environment as you that's can
be a big problem for instance it might
be really tricky to install tensorflow
and then fully flexible apps these are
like anything goes but then you have to
with everything with great power comes
great responsibility
ok so now I'm just gonna run over a
little bit of coaches comparing to apps
I'm gonna compare ok and shiny just to
see like the flavor of how they look
yeah so here is the app that I used to
make this these charts that I showed
earlier so what I do is I have this app
and then you can just save like this is
this is actually bouquet yeah calling
from our so the bouquet library has like
back-end code also has like JavaScript
code and there's an R wrapper for the
JavaScript code so in a way this is sort
of like sneaking in a little bit of
Python into your our world which is
always a good thing
ok cool so the code to make this looks
like this at least a pseudo code I am
hiding some code paradigm of shiny is
really let's see if I can can you yeah
you have like the UI and then you have
the server there's like a very clear
distinction about you like what is the
front end code that you're gonna write
what is the back end code that you're
gonna write and look at how I mean this
is so sure this is like I don't know how
many lines of code is this but this is
really small so for the UI we will
define like a sidebar layout so you have
the filters on the left and you have the
the main panel the like our bouquet
output on the right the way that we pass
information along is through a global
input variable so right here this is
going to pass like the slight like the
language input into variable called
input language and this is gonna pass
like work or or like want like whether
you want to work with this language or
whether you want to or whether you have
worked with it that widget is here in
that Goodson relationship so then in the
server this code is like looped over and
over and over again and what it does is
it looks for like what is the state of
the widgets what is the input language
where does the input relationship this
like creating a new title for the chart
then we filter our data based on that
and then we plot the figure and what's
kind of powerful with this it's like we
can ply plot any kind of figure you're
we could plot a GG plot we could plot
our bouquet plot Lee there's like many
different things we would have to change
this up here but it's it's pretty
similar so then the K the connection
here this code will look for like what
is the current widget state if any of
like the filters have changed it will
change the plot then it passes the
change to the output which is the bar
chart and then right here this is saying
here's the bar chart it's saying okay
plot this so then you'll see in the UI
the change immediately great and then
you just call it with shiny app UI UI
down here awesome so this is the similar
app made with bouquet some less familiar
with okay and it took me I'd say quite a
lot longer to build this app I haven't
done some things uh looks very similar
there's no X access so xkcd would be
would be angry at me and rightfully so
because what is the x-axis yeah okay and
this is the code to to generate this so
there's a lot more code than I'm hiding
up here where I set up some global
variables like here's the data frame the
pandas dataframe widget state is as a
global dictionary that I created and
that just says like okay what is what
are the filters out right now and then I
actually created the bouquet bar chart
up here as well so that's like the first
thing that happens so the paradigm here
is not there's really not like the clear
the clear UI server like definitive
opinion I think that this is probably
like more like the standard way of
thinking about these apps with callbacks
so it's it's definitely more like it's
definitely more what is like the
standard for how you do these but less
like maybe easy and intuitive for
someone who hasn't done it before
so what we do here is we create the
widgets and then we create the bar chart
and that gets played in the layout down
here so that's where the layout is and
then we add callbacks to the to the
filters here so like the radio buttons
the Select they each have a handler and
then the handlers what we do is we
update the global state okay so as the
widget change state at that global in
Python I don't remember the last time I
actually called global in Python not
always a good idea but necessary here
and then we update the bar chart and
then the bar chart does what you
expected filters the data based on the
current widget state updates the title
sorts the axes sort of a hack to get to
saw everything by percent so it's like
nice and clean so the most so the
largest thing is at the top of the bar
chart and the smallest is the bottom and
then what it does is it updates the data
it doesn't actually update the it
doesn't actually specifically update the
chart what it does is it updates like a
global variable called source which has
the data for the chart so we're just
upping the data behind the chart that's
going in there but then at the bottom we
like so here's the current document then
we add the layout that when we want to
run these it's a command-line utility
it's like okay serve and then that just
works okay so kind of the takeaways from
this these are my takeaways like our
shiny is like really popular and I think
rightfully so it integrates with like
everything that our users already know
they know ggplot2 they know like our
studio they're already using it it's an
older like it's been around for a while
so there's tons of the documentation
examples very quick to get started ok
server a little bit of a learning curve
slightly more verbose pretty powerful
though and the bouquet code that you use
like the plotting code if you learn that
you can use that in Jupiter notebooks as
well so you can kind of like you don't
have to learn one thing just for one
purpose
awesome so everything so far has been
kind of like the dashboard this is this
is usually what you might share data
like it's like here's the - we're here
the charts explaining charts so you can
filter the charts but there's more that
you can do with data science Web Apps
and I think this is actually what's
really interesting because this is kind
of like since this is like new this is
like stuff that we haven't been able to
do with data before and so this is gonna
like open up I think a lot of
opportunities in like what we can do
okay
so here is a I don't I don't know if
this is actually great but it's moving
it's kind of interesting so what this is
showing is volcanic eruptions for the
last 200 years so like this is showing
the Pacific what is the Ring of Fire
like Indonesia Japan the Aleutian
Islands in Alaska most volcanoes in the
US actually happened in Alaska which is
a fun fact all of this is actually
embedded in the browser which is really
cool so there's no server running this
and this is all our code and write any
JavaScript so I don't know if you'd use
it but I think it's cool this is more
useful so this is a clustering tool that
one of my colleagues wrote so what this
is doing here is it's helping someone to
find how to like pick keywords to
cluster things so right here I was
typing in like sort of baseball terms
there's a twenty newsgroups data backing
this this is saying like here are these
words what are similar like what words
did I forget and then adding them in and
this is like creating a cluster a text
cluster or topic you supernova baseball
supernova they obviously go together
galactic black hole seems like it's
working pretty well this one is
definitely the cooler topic absolutely
so then we can set the topics this is
like JSON and then it'll go to the top
here and then we can show that like
using this tool we can use these topics
and it will actually like classify the
document itself and give us a bar chart
so this is all built with iPad widgets
the Jupiter widgets
I think it's kind of amazing I haven't
seen anything else this extensive built
with Jupiter widgets it's running in a
notebook so you couldn't you couldn't
like serve this over the Internet
you'd have to pass them the actual
notebook to run and that's sort of just
like the design of of jupiter notebooks
i I wonder if that's going to change
with Jeep here lads
it very well may so that's real cool
Mike is awesome and here is like one
last app this is another shiny app and
this is an app used to like to find it
so that employees that service can find
mentors so like if you want to know
something about deep learning you would
say like who civis knows about deep
learning that I could ask questions to
and with me about this is it's accessing
data from Google Docs so if the company
everyone will type in like this is what
I know it's just volunteering you put it
in Google Docs that's like it the data
input and then this will just pull that
data and like have this nice friend it's
built with shiny and shiny dashboards I
think that this layout looks really cool
I think it looks like pretty
professional and I was built by another
one of my colleagues ok great so just
kind of wrapping up all of these things
that you can kind of do with data
science web apps like beyond just
showing reports which is which is
already a big big win to to be able to
like create your reports with with
programmatic code but you can do more
like live optimizations so we have one
thing that we do for a client where we
have like this kind of custom
optimization and like a bunch of filters
and the client will like put all these
filters in and then the optimization
will run and say I'll put a turn so like
this is the choice you should make and
that's been really successful we have
like real-time model scoring model
inspection they were talking about lying
yesterday it's very cool so you can
imagine you could build an app where
somebody has an image and they upload
the image to the app and then it says
like here are the objects in this app
and then it also shows you like with
lime or shop is shape is another one to
do this that I don't know to you
although like here
is why it's making this prediction so
you get like both what is predicting and
why so you can like actually trust that
it's doing something useful this is sort
of I showed like a clustering app that
you could use I can also think that you
can use data science web apps for like
matching this is a problem that that we
work on as well so it's sort of
unsupervised in the sense that you don't
always have like a label data set and
you want to like see how we're my match
is actually doing like is this matching
things reasonable like what is it
missing like when it is low confidence
like what does that look like when it's
high confidence what does that look like
and if you build an application a lot
faster you do that otherwise you're
writing a lot of sequel queries but
sequel is awesome but just not as fast
and then finally I can think of like
human-in-the-loop apps this would be
really cool so you can imagine an app
where you have an image and and you have
a model and it classifies that like the
image and it gives you like the top 20
predictions for that and then you say
like okay which you have a human like
actually like look and see which one
which of these is correct and then you
like gain more data and then the model
improves over time and that's just a
much faster way to do this well
especially then like some things just
have to be annotated and if you can use
like some machine learning is like a
starting point then you aren't it's not
like you're starting from a random point
and then you have to take so much more
time to get something use a lot of it
okay so that is a very brief and fast
introduction to the data science web app
scheme this is fun so now we have time
for questions
[Applause]
certainly
in the back I don't know
so this is this is tough and this is
actually like again this is like the
biggest kind of the biggest reason why
we even started looking in this I don't
I don't want to I want to pick one I
kind of think that like if something was
related to Jupiter that's sort of what
everybody knows that sort of the brand
name in our community there's like our
studio is the company so whatever
Headley Wickham does or whatever our
studio does that's what everybody uses
and that's a it's a gift and a curse
right so it's not like you don't really
necessarily want like one group to like
only have control of a whole language
but then you do kind of like know like
this is what everybody else is gonna use
this is what I should learn so I don't
know we miss the - talked yesterday that
is a pretty promising approach so - has
like a conception of like it uses like
react templates so that should be pretty
nice to create and then it has like a
flask backend so I'm pretty excited
about - yeah okay yeah so let me just
flip back for a second I can show you
some things so like I mean if you you
this is like just what you would you'd
have like a website and then they would
navigate to this website and the what
they would see is this I didn't open a
browser because I didn't want anything
to go wrong so this is just one take on
screen caps yeah yeah that's a good
question
so it's not there's not uh there are
many ways to do it this is like one
thing that like we're trying to sell is
like a good way to host these not just
in terms of like hosting them is one
thing but then there's also like maybe
these are running job
in the background so like an easy way to
like run the jobs in a secure
environment so I think a lot of times
you're probably gonna have to pay to
deploy these but all the code is open
source let's go back here I can't why
just leave it on this cuz yeah any other
questions
sure I'm happy to show the slides I
think if I'm not mistaken PI data like
post the YouTube and then like you send
PI to the slides as well so I think that
probably through PI data will be the
easiest way to find them yeah another
question sorry say that again oh that is
so so the question is how do you
maintain these web apps which is a
brilliant question so this is I mean so
this is the interesting thing so like
again with great power comes great
responsibility so if you develop this
app somebody's gonna have to maintain it
if you like pass it to your client so
this is why like you should usually do
as little as you like make your app as
simple as it can so it's not going to
break so like in our company we kind of
share responsibility I'm on the hook for
a bunch of these apps sometimes we pass
them along to we have a dedicated
engineering team and then you have Pedro
duty
any final questions so let me unpack
your question so can you so in terms of
can you make can you make the output
look like what you can do from SHINee
yes and if you make an are you asking
can you make the like like the syntax
like how you program it look like how
you program SHINee sure so like - does
have it in a different interface that
might be more similar to our SHINee I
also think that like I guess you
definitely can you definitely can I'm
not sure it's always like the right
approach is just to like do exactly what
Chinese doing cuz like in some ways like
why not just use SHINee if you really
want that and like it's not necessarily
pythonic it's a little magic so I don't
necessarily know if like that's the
right choice and developers like okay
[Music]
wow that's that's like hitting the nail
on the head I think so
I don't really want to like offer any
preferences but just to recap what you
said so you're saying like in the our
land Headley is basically rewriting a
DSL for our and that's it's called the
tidy verse and in Python everything is
kind of sticking to like trying to be
pythonic is like the API and not writing
things that are easier to use
quote-unquote but but aren't like
pythonic I don't know I I think that
like the world needs everything so you
need both and I think the pythons
philosophy of like like do the thing
that's like like has the least surprised
does make sense a lot and maybe there's
more surprises and the our syntax though
is really wonderful if anyone learns are
like our consultants like that are like
not they don't care about programming
like they care about getting stuff out
the door they love it so I think that
there's a there's a lot to be gained
from understanding what's going on there
cool thanks everyone
[Applause]